Everyone here in Gridiron Heights
is gearing up for the only game
that truly matters:
the Pro Bowl.
AGAIN.
You boys didn’t practice for two whole days
to lose this game. AGAIN.
CLEAR EYES.
FULL HEARTS.
PRO BOWL!!!
Coach, I got the votes.
I can play.
Son, I am so proud of you.
You’re a Pro Bowl alternate.
Here’s to God
football
and the 2019 AFC Pro Bowl team.
AFC FOREVER!!!
You guys are my brothers.
Hey, I’m JuJu by the way.
I play for the Steelers.
- My name is Keenan Allen.
- Hi I’m Quenton Nelson.
- Nice to meet you.
Wow.
The Camping World Stadium in Orlando, Florida.
Doesn’t get much better than this.
They play the Citrus Bowl here...
OK boys, we’re just going to play
good ol’ half-speed football
with minimal tackling.
OH, I’M SO BUMMED
I CAN’T PLAY IN THIS BIG GAME.
WIN THIS FOR ME, SON.
Pro Bowls and memories.
That’s all you got.
YOU BEST PLAY 3!
YOU’RE EMBARRASSING ME, COACH.
3...you’re in.
Hut hut!
Wilson takes the snap.
Oh, Miller’s coming for him!
There you go. There you go.
Goodnight.
[Gasps]
We want to apologize to the millions
and millions of children
at home watching the Pro Bowl.